some ways when you look at the tale of
OJ Simpson it goes well beyond OJ
Simpson and it really is a conversation
and a story that involves everything in
our culture race celebrity power
masculinity the criminal justice system
so the media like it goes on and on and
on and on and I think people respond to
this story specifically in terms of who
they are and where they come from black
white young old male female there are
something in this film that will
personally speak to you know Jays Drive
I think was very simple and he says it
plainly in an interview that's in the
first hour of the documentary he said
when I walk down the street I want
people to know me he had an ambition to
be famous from the time he was young he
never damn Bishan to be the greatest
football player ever he didn't have an
ambition to be rich in an ambition to be
famous now what that means in some ways
is OJ had also had an ambition to be
loved and loved by everybody and I think
it informs this story in a very powerful
way because it speaks to how all of us
were seduced by him and the image that
we saw on the screen both frankly as a
football player not just because he was
wildly successful but that he was so
graceful on the football field so
beautiful in a way that when we're
watching as a as a viewer as a fan he
brought us pleasure he brought in so
we're connected to this guy even though
he's just an image on the screen and the
same goes for him when we saw him
running through the airport and Hertz
commercials you know I as a young kid
growing up adopted that when I was in
the airport and I would try to be like
see people in front of me I would try to
avoid people and run around them like I
was okay running through the airport and
so there's this thing that we feel like
we know this person that we feel
connected to this person and it informed
so much of why we were so shocked and
why it was just it was incomprehensible
someone like that could stand accused of
murder when we enjoyed such it wasn't
just by the way because oh he's a good
guy and he's the guy I knew down the
street from me it's that he brought us
so much pleasure and the celebrity
aspect to me is well that helps explain
culturally a level of complicitous that
we all have in building him into what we
built him into and so it shouldn't be
shocking that we were all sort of taken
aback and we all were so emotionally
invested in this thing in 1994-95
because it was so much more than just
about OJ Simpson and whether or not he
was a murderer what I already brought to
this story as far as my personal
knowledge my knowledge of OJ as a
football player my knowledge for
instance of you know of him being going
to USC from the projects in Potrero Hill
and knowing where USC was geographically
located next to watts I came to it with
the story I came to it with a notion of
okay what I know is that Oh Jay is this
guy who notoriously tried to distance
himself from his blackness Oh Jay was
put on trial in 1994 and he became a
referendum on race in America he was as
a defendant sort of race was primarily
used to help acquit him how do I get
from here to there that's the irony in
this story how did this group of people
who live beside him when he was at USC
when he was in this bubble how do we get
to a place over here where those people
who he had nothing to do with all of a
sudden were so invested in him there are
little things like that that I start off
with as premises and then I go well
that's the narrative I want to tell I'm
gonna at least go down these two paths
simultaneously knowing that they're
going to intersect 20 to 30 years later
how specifically I'm going to weave
those two things together that's more
that's that's a that's editing that's
further thought that's writing that's
editing but you have to start off with
an idea to guide you as you're going
along we're dealing with a story where
unfortunately so much is so
much of what has been done in relation
to it has been so thoughtless
salacious sensationalist and so when
people sit down with someone who has
thought a lot about it and is interested
in the substantive parts of the story
and the seriousness of it and not the
the salacious maybe they are they maybe
they were refreshed maybe they thought
okay this is someone I can finally speak
to about these things that have been in
my head for so many years but frankly no
one wants to engage me about it in this
way because in the end this is history
this was a document of history and that
was the pitch to everyone sit down and
tell me your story and I'll respect your
story I'm not going to not gonna chop up
your story in a little bit so it's
unrecognizable no you get you you fully
get to be heard